someone once said that the best way to
learn about a city is to leave your
hotel room and meet the locals you guys
have been friends for how long yeah how
do you refer to each other like if
you're two Australians do you just say
hey mate you can add on the end of the
name so you could be peace jonathan
becomes John Oh John Ellen what's your
name Jim becomes Jim Jim out would I be
Conan Oh Oh your car no I'd be count out
if you'd Gary all right I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna sit down and pretend
we're all three really good mates that
have known each other for four years
I'm cono Jonah Jim oh and let's just
talk and use as much Australian slang as
you can okay we're gonna keep that John
Oh John Oh Jimoh Jimoh and Conan oh do
you think you got that this time got at
this time just say nice to meet you we
have been friends for years we share a
flat together
okay spent ages we've been at all okay
we've done it all I've been in jail for
a little bit okay okay we don't want to
talk about what I did I don't think I
really did it but they say I did here we
go long days may way
[Applause]
shirani barrels though bow
yeah yeah get out through the barrel
battles right through the barrels and
then you know you're in a Billabong I'm
dee Bundy billabong Hamdi Bundy put them
on suddenly I'm a man at work and then
over there you know yeah exactly but
fair dinkum hey what hey Jonna you're a
little mumsy with the tongue see what's
going on hey we gotta do this more often
why aren't we doing this more often hey
sorry I was in prison not your phone
well it actually was my flowers I did it
so I've just been talking to people I
like your country a lot it's amazing the
people are very laid-back - very nice on
and on everything's quite regulated he
saw issues there a carnival was about
absolutely every Jess I've noticed that
here's the thing the ads they show us in
America but Australia like Australia
come on down and he took this country
full of pirates made you dressed like
this be in bed at 9 o'clock at night
we've been really drunk when you're
wearing this outfit my school principal
tonight that I've never been you've
never had alcohol have you
not now you know what never you've never
said a bad word a curse word not and
you've never committed any illegal act I
have never seen never sin I am a few off
in every sense of the word yes Qi in
every sense young where I'll be as a
young child
yes you just keep talking I'm gonna try
and I sound just like you keep going
yeah so we like to speak like these we
like to speak like they want to speak
like we like to speak one man right yeah
you're from Henry Henry and retainers
are no where's the suburbs
anyway I'm running out of things to say
I ran out of things to say about 14
years ago I need to take down a nice to
meet you sir
such an honor what I get I want to get a
selfie or something yeah all right